all right Carolyn Carolyn where are you
from originally where did you grow up
braon Texas Bron tell me about your
family growing up my mother and my
dad they
worked and we went to school as
kids as I grew up things start
happening I got M age of seven he want
to go back to
school by who
my dad's
brother
un just come around my dad and drink all
the
time he came in the bedroom that
night put his hand over my
mouth
and and his V keeps me
screaming
a girl
terrorized if I told anyone he would
kill
me I ain't like that I when I went to
school but it still bother
me and I finally told my dad at the age
of
13 you want to why it took me so
long I start smoking weed
how
[Music]
drugs going through
it want to finish school none of
that what kind of kid were you in high
school straight
stud
athletic after you graduated what uh
what did you
do went to fire
cam you know went to
prison went to fire C what was that
for San
dieo where did you go to Fire camp
for just need
time to get myself
together to refrain from what
happened and as I grew up I just
went I in the
field stud student I gave
up
cuz I thought everybody was against
me and then as I got older I felt
building myself
up to stay strong no matter what
happened in
life but I still had to continue drugs
in order not to
remember what happened
okay so I try to feel little
ANS so I SM
cocaine did your
family do anything about what they found
out when you were 13
no no how did that make you
feel
youy GRE up trusting no
man
a family me I want to kill
him it's
hard so the more I smoke the better I
feel the more I drink the better I feel
cuz I don't want to
remember you only feel the
void
self-destruction
on the influence of drugs and
alcohol this I took control so I can
forget about what
happened but you done aside I wanted him
hurt I right here today what I'm going
through right now
I for the time of the moment I know I've
been in the hospital
myself I want to R tell you so
bad after all to still
hurt cuz I don't want about hurting
me you
know
trauma took a
toe seizures to
Tool you feel like what happened to you
as a young girl is what you feel like
that redirect did your whole
life yeah it's turn me
down a family me all I can think of all
these
sh this
retaliation in meantime time I got hurt
in
accident do damage forever I want to
live I want to keep hurting myself or
killing myself I just want him
dead what goes on in life I know I got
to live on there
time but what
help
cuz I ain't got nobody that I don't no
real people you
know SM than fifth
grader but I never give up no matter
what position I'm
in I never give
up you have children why
were you able to raise your child yes me
and my
mom but I got to go what he's doing time
now I'm sorry who's doing time he's
doing time now your son
[Music]
yeah I just got to get myself
well
how long have You' been on the
streets 20
years over
know and drugs are part of your life
yes correct yes
stabilization I use it for
pain
I st myself not around a lot of
people I can only look out me and take
care of me
now you let to be home and take care of
my
son I just had to
releas what's inside of me
you
know you can talk to everyone
everybody my feelings and what I'm going
through one day when God heal me I'll be
better all I must do is to stay focused
and build myself up and stop tear me
down cuz I'm much more stronger than
that but I need a time to get away to
you
know to revive you know to
rethink but I never forget you know
but what happened to me I don't want to
happen to anybody else
either to stopped them from growing or
whatever but it took me a long time to
get it
out did he do any time or anything like
that at that AG didn't believe was Kid
is you
know but throughout my suffering I tell
you I suffer for Christ
sake let God take
[Music]
heav I grew up
now J to see your
birthday
63 years praise the
Lord life is
beautiful but I have to stand
strong no matter what I go
through but I have to releve the the
pain you
know so w't check it out anyone
else if you had your life to live all
over again what would you have done
differently finish school and teach the
other children when they grow
up cuz I love
children cuz how can make it they can
to feeling an emotion it's like you
can't tell to anyone anybody you to talk
to a person that's that's
understandable just direct you know
feelings emotions and
hurt I don't let it have I'm
protected even know somebody El children
not there or whatever I'm very
protected that's my safety
security cuz if they were there for me I
know I'll be
saved that shouldn't never happen
happened to
me but no matter
what I finished what I
started even with the drug
counseling the mentality the person had
when the brain w it's
wonderful when you explore it and do it
cuz life is wor
living no matter what you go through in
life have your 20 years on SK Ro in as a
woman okay cuz I'm going to open
you to
myself don't worry about the mity
whatever
respect just
temporarily try I get to handle my
paperwork and
stuff
what's your biggest fear at this point
in your
life me that are
dangerous you take advantage of
women what happened to your to your
right eye regular
coma you're in a wheelchair for
what never down and I got a lawsuit just
stck a needle in my leg in the left leg
for no par
reason this is not
me but I'm alive praise the Lord you
know
I know one thing if God is for me who
can be against me
right that's all the good I've done I
never
satisy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
Retreat and always believe in
God cuz he deliver you in times of
trouble you always let me no matter
what don't let nobody do more damage to
me I already done to
myself
let go let God regain control of my
life build me up cuz I'm a strong
Confident
Woman the God in my life I am
somebody and I prefer to live I
die long as I got God I will be all
right
all right joh thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome
sir and thank you for
listening